welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilk sure host and our guest is
Yuri Sergei of a former ukrainian
diplomat and politician who has served
as permanent representative of Ukraine
to the United Nations he is here at Yale
as a visiting fellow in the council on
European studies at the macmillan center
today we'll talk with ambassador sergey
f about the current state of Ukraine's
government welcome ambassador thank you
for inviting me it's a pleasure for us
to have you it's my honor so let's begin
with a kind of an overview of what's
going on in Ukraine today a few days ago
the Prime Minister Yatsenyuk resigned
and when we are speaking now so the
Coalition is gambling the composition of
a new coalition and the converted
configuration of your government so it
was announced that the elections of the
new government and the creation of new
coalition supposed to be today but still
still they are working on that there are
there are difficulties because well
different different members of the
coalition they have different views on
on the future of the government okay and
how would you characterize the
government as a whole you know for the
past few years well this is a pity
because we are repeating the same
mistakes if we come back to the Orange
Revolution and the composition of
government at the beginning was correct
because it was composed of those who
share the same views but unfortunately
they lost this trend and the create a
new composition were the parties who
were not in the same line were invited
and it was very strange composition of
the government or one had we had the
patriotic president Yushchenko and his
opponent Yanukovych as a prime minister
who later became the president the same
we we have now and unfortunately be
approaching the same composition if if
the politicians managed to overcome
these disagreements was probably this
time you'll succeed okay you were on
campus a couple days ago you attended a
a roundtable panel discussion and you'd
mentioned some reforms that you believe
need to happen in Ukraine can you tell
us a little bit more about that so it's
clear what we are to do first of all
vism we should learn the lessons from
our way past from the twenties of the
last century when we had the same the
same problems the main pro kind of
problem the problem is that first of all
our political business and public
leaders the the are to find the common
language and not to conflict among
themselves this the old ukrainian game
when we have three leaders in the power
so all of them they want to be an
emperor so that's what we observing now
when the Prime Minister the president
they are conflicting for the power so
first of all we need the synergy we need
the compromise between those who who
gained this revolution second we need to
double it Assize our business and the
commercialize our politics because
people they are looking how to protect
their business being in the politics and
the politicians they are looking how to
gain money and so this is a very
dangerous dangerous lessons from the
past we ought to land now naturally we
know the problems from the past that if
we manage to overcome we will succeed
first of all we are to get rid of the
Soviet system of my
judgment and what when you say Soviet
system of management what you saw as a
Soviet system of management is when
government wants to lead everything and
to control even private business
including the media including the media
unfortunately we have a new invention
one media from the state-owned they are
coming to the private owned and the the
owners their business people they're
either in politics or in business or
both and so that's why we do not have
exactly independent mediums so this is
something which we are too or come
naturally regulations they are very
draconic if you permit me to use that
because it creates the the basis for the
corruption one government wants to
regulate business so it means that
business is looking how to overcome that
so the second is the taxation politics
which is very awful and it reminds the
the Soviet type of the management of the
Soviet economy when the county that the
best way to have the profitability of
any of any enterprise let's take the
cohort saw horse diary for example the
Soviet leader is the the count that the
best way to bring the profitability for
them it was to feed cows less and to
milk them more so it brought to the
collapse of the system and know what we
observe and it's broadly known as the
corruption in Ukraine because as well of
this high-tech taxation people are
trying to avoid a tax paying the keeping
their business fifty percent in the
shadow the figures which are coming from
IMF and many of them they are moving
their money their business or in
Offshore's so the last candle Panama
scandal gives these the Ukrainian
examples as well so all the problems are
well known they are from our way past
and so this is what in on the papers of
throw recommendations from
European Union employment IMF well so
for the new garment is exactly challenge
how to overpass bypass to cope with all
this old problems how would you
characterize Ukraine's relationship with
Russia particularly in light of the
recent annexation of Crimea well
unfortunately unfortunately what we have
today we are on the down of the possible
neighborhood conflict so we lost trust
we we started to lose it from the very
beginning of our gained independence
when Russia openly declared that the
only post Soviet state is Russia who
lost and others gained and so Putin
today declared that the biggest tragedy
of the of this collapse of the Soviet
Union is the collapse of the Soviet
Union and the the problem is that we
will have this tensions between our
countries until Russian leadership keeps
the position not recognizing crane as a
state the recent statement of madera von
putin what the doubted if Ukraine is a
state at all so that's why it would be
very difficult to to bring back the
trust the confidence unfortunately the
Russian propaganda inside propaganda
brought the image of Ukrainian as a
fascist and what happened two years ago
as a burr Lucien in our interpretation
it was a coup d'etat fascist coup d'etat
in their interpretation so they managed
to bring this hostility into their
society the the bloody conflict on the
east of Ukraine which took thousands of
Ukrainians and thousands of Russian
soldiers also
a a better example and it will remain
for generations in a memory but
something was and is wrong between us to
overcome it so we need first of all to
to have it to have a changes in the in
Moscow fast they are to behave as as all
the European countries to be democratic
to be open and and to create
neighborhood we can't change
unfortunately our neighbors well
geography is something we are connected
entirely but Jo strategy is something
which gives us a chance do you worry
that Russia might take more of Ukraine I
don't think that they are ready to do
that because they don't have resources I
mean they do understand that if the if
the movie had the for sure for sure they
will have a serious resistance from the
from the vest which is for the time
being performed in a soft way but any
kind of further offence you will bring
the reaction of the west of the mall in
the most wrong way so put in a phrase
that pudding doesn't want to be isolated
fool but for him it is also very
dangerous to step back because he will
not be on this understood well by his
society whose patriotism he raised to do
to the propaganda for him it's better to
to keep the conflict frozen do you think
there was enough of an outcry by the
United States perhaps by the UN in terms
of Putin taking over part of your
country what happened to two years ago
brought all the world around to a very
very shocking situation so the world was
not prepared to this scenario
then you in a Russian leadership it is
not the the Soviet type of the of the
people they are well well educated
they're in the business they are
globalized they invested a lot outside
and they excited a lot of investment
from outside the West was seriously
engaged with Russia Russia was engaged
with the West seriously in gas deals in
oil deals and whatever and so the West
Was was shocked with that and that's why
reaction from the West was not adequate
to what Russia did by annexing Crimea so
the soft sanctions then when Russia
continued the their fancy on these of
Ukraine the sanctions were most longer
directed to the painful parts of Russian
interest the economy Sakura stone and
naturally sanctions did their job so it
was it was this way of a reaction some
of her Ukrainians they expected that
well was probably West would come to
fight for us but well frankly the West
was not ready for that and nobody wanted
to fight with Russia nobody wanted to to
escalate the conflict and to bring the
regional or even a continental war if
not more that's why the West took this
this position trying to appease Russia
and to bring the soft deterrence well
using the the sanctions but sort the
West still demonstrate solidarity with
Ukraine and the the recent meaning of g7
in Japan demonstrated solidarity and the
strong message to Moscow well stop what
you are doing is drawing forces from the
east and do not forget
that Crimea annexation will never be
accepted by the West because the United
Nations took the resolution on
territorial integrity and because of
unprecedented action Russia performed
after the second world war in Europe do
you think there will be will come a time
when Ukraine will have Crimea back for
sure it will take time so no military
solution for that it's it's absolutely
clear the only way to bring back or two
ways if we won first of all Ukrainians
should demonstrate that we have a well
successful successful story to attract
by our reforms the civil society our
European perspectives when the crimeans
will have a chance to see something
different they used to have now and what
they had before being in Ukraine so the
second is it's very clear that Russia
has no resources to keep Crimea floating
Crimea doesn't have the economic
resources no natural resources the only
way for them in the past to succeed was
tourism but now tourism is blocked by
the the United Nation resolution and the
decision of United Nations bodies
including the International to this
organization including a cow which
forbids the flights to Crimea and so on
it's it means that if Crimea stays in
that position the fate of aphasia which
used to be the best place for recreation
in the Soviet Union and now this desert
desert desert and so in ruins and so on
it will happen with Crimea if no changes
comes Russia doesn't have money doesn't
have human resources to to keep them
floating for the Ukrainians living in
in Crimea when this all happened did the
majority of them stay or did they move
were they allowed to move to the rest of
the country well it's difficult question
but we have a very correct question
because why it happened first of all it
happened illegally Russia through the
pro-russian groupings there the
organized a non-legal illegal referendum
based on the alleged rights of
russian-speaking population to to have
their self-determination so it's against
any international rules playing in the
same way Russia could pretend through
encouraging the Russian sleeper
population in brooklyn in New York a lot
of people from the former Soviet Union
and so if to follow this line they have
a ride for self-determination declare
Brooklyn as an independent state so it
was illegally done so it was done under
the force and that's why the United
Nations took the decision not to
recognize anything there so they brought
military man regular and similar
regulars and and others and so under the
threat this referendum took place but
the problem is that Ukrainian mistake in
Crimea was also visible because we did
nothing first of all to have Crimea be
integrated to Ukrainian well European
perspectives to bring them jobs to
create these jobs to feel them
comfortable with new Ukrainian
configuration after the Soviet Union
collapsed so we did less to bring them
new opportunities and so the they
believed that under Russia they could
have something
something more positive to make the
people living there welcomed some again
some of them yes but we are to
understand the composition of the
population both in a pair in Crimea and
some Baltic States in the Soviet time it
was not easy for four people to move
from one place to another place and to
settle themselves without any permission
so it was very very regulated so some of
the places like resorts recreation
places they were allowed only for the
selected part of the population for army
persons KGB political and so on so this
why Crimea and the Baltic States and
Caucasian littoral zone was populated by
the retired Soviet guys and so that's
why the am so nervous in Baltic States
that's why it is a fifth column for
Russia to inspire them to raise that's
why Russia paid attention mmm and varied
them doing all these years of our
independence while supporting
encouraging this pro-russian pro-russian
ideas Crimean Tatars who we invited from
the exile so also was not well well
adapted in independent Ukraine and so
but but crimean tatars and ukrainians
they were against all this referendum
but the the they were not strong enough
to raise ukraine did not want to use
well force to protect and so that's why
what we got almost all Crimean Tatars
they move to Ukraine Ukrainians the move
to Ukraine some of them they are there
they are trying to keep their own
Ukrainian citizenship but unfortunately
the
the new the new authorities who demanded
to to take the Russian citizenship so
they are a very difficult situation so
for Ukraine what do you think the future
holds in terms of in terms of
politically we are to not to repeat the
lessons we should create the Solidarity
of all our elite's business lines
political eyes the public persons to be
dedicated to any to proceed with state
buildings we should understand that all
the reforms they are badly needed and we
liking with all these reforms during the
last two years after the revolution so
we don't have time that's why we need to
implement all three phones immediately
luckily we have support from European
Union from our partners United States
IMF and we have all the chances to do
that we should not focused on the other
membership with European Union because
now we have association not for
membership but for partnership but not
to use a disassociation as the mechanism
for modernization and mechanism for the
reforms an ortho membership because
European Union also is in any trouble
but the model is bad and then you
usually have before in the unit on the
Soviet Union so reforms are needed
people are there there they are tired
for 25 years after we regained our
independence there they are tire with
what we are trying to do and in doing so
but it depends on on us we can't we
can't lose this this chance because the
third revolution the third my done will
bring only
so so some some hopes still existing in
a society awaiting what composition of
the government will be finally worried
in the parliament of course the the
ruling party the president and the Prime
Minister they lost a lot in their rates
because they they have lost time to
bring reforms well so this is a chance
again and we are waiting what the
Department will bring her to us okay
very good thank you for being here with
us today thank you for inviting me thank
you for more information about
ambassador sergey please visit our
website at macmillan report led you be
sure to join us again for another
episode of the macmillan report made
possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale